Meet the Robinsons is kind of like
Chicken Little if it had a touch more
heart to it but the downside is that has
the same problems as Chicken Little way
too many jokes have way too many styles
and way too many characters that don't
have a whole lot of focus I guess I feel
a little bit more for this movie though
because the message while very simple I
thought was actually developed much
better than other films development the
message of perseverance learning to live
with your failures but still finding the
energy to move on just wish the rest of
the movie was devoted as the message was
very well the story centers around a
young boy genius
he makes a ton of inventions that
constantly get some weird books all the
time and also end up blowing up in his
face as if the kid wasn't odd enough he
comes across another little boy who says
that he's from the future looking mostly
to have fun and cause trouble he takes
the boy genius with him and shows him
off to his family this is as you would
guess the Robinsons a very odd assembly
a very strangely designed and strangely
talking and somewhat memorable but
mostly forgettable crew of oddballs most
of the time just like the movie is spent
always on the go always doing something
oh we saying something oh he's doing
something energized with some form of
action by God look at how they eat
dinner fired surely that is not the best
you can do
yeah it's that kind of movie but an evil
villain comes around determined to take
the little boy's inventions and make him
his own knowing for a fact that his
potential will one day change the world
there's one or two twists in the movie
that I think most adults can see coming
but for kids they're actually not bad
twins but some of them get really weird
like the actual relationship between the
family and the boy genius is well when
you really think about it
maybe a little too uncomfortable kind of
Freudian when you get down to it in
another film maybe they would dive more
into this and the psychological
ramifications but it's Disney it's a
kids movie of course they're not gonna
do that they shouldn't have to do that
but those weird uncomfortable thoughts
are still put in our minds once they
show it to us but as I said before
that's not the film's only problem its
ambition is way too much for its own
good
every second something is flying
something is popping something is
whoosing by a character is shouting or
saying a weird line or just doing
something strange the designs are pretty
cool but we never really have time to
sit down and let them sink in it's just
constant weirdness upon weirdness upon
weirdness and it's not well paced to a
point where it just becomes so much
overload that none of it sinks in
occasionally there's a joke that works
or there's a character that's kind of
fun or I don't know I guess it means
well so I can't be that harsh but I just
feel like it's trying too hard the big
redeeming factor as I said before is the
message and the way it's portrayed
there's a very good quote at the end and
I won't ruin what it is or who says it
but it does leave you with just kind of
a good feeling as you're exiting the
theater just what I can say for some
other Disney CG films does that make it
a good movie no it's bad it's pretty
clumsy and not very well put together
but I have a bit of a soft spot maybe
just for the message of love it's a
strange little experiment from Disney
that never really went anywhere you can
see why but I'll at least give it an A
for ambition
you